this is the theme the bismillah al
hamdulillah salamo alaikum peace be unto
you you are watching the dean show I'm
Eddie your host thank you for tuning in
again today we're going to be talking
about spirituality some of us give
really really depressed at times that's
the nature of this life and now how do
you become more spiritual you have to
shut the lights off throw some candles
on the table and just throw your head
from side to side and wait some some
some some Holy Spirit to come in you and
you start speaking in tongues what is it
what does this mean so we're going to be
talking about this with our next guest
in a second here on a diesel don't go
nowhere this is the thing
this is the this is the assalamu alaikum
my knee comes set out for the catcher
please be with you my brother and with
you as well thank you for being with us
on the Dean shows a clock that's a
pleasure to be here I got a gift for you
just like a little now this is the DVD
that we have of the Dean show nice I
have to figure out something to give you
Chris courage to give gifts in Islam
indeed that's my gift to you jazaka
allahu that thank you very much i really
appreciate it you're welcome so you have
your own section at the Dean show calm
people go there and see the other show
okay just take a minute just to kind of
let our viewers know who you are for
those that already don't know okay
basically i was born in Montreal Canada
and growing up you know al hamdulillah I
had a passion for the religion so
eventually I went overseas and learn to
Arabic at the Islamic University of
Medina and further pursue the bachelors
in cydia after that I came back and I
signed up with a mockup and I'm actually
one of their hadith instructors I teach
hadith and my second and newest class
right now is called a Shamir mohammedia
all those things that are specific to
the prophet salallahu on you set them in
terms of characteristics and traits
likewise I council the community
especially marital counseling youth
counseling any sort of trouble is that
the community has I try to help them out
as much as I can and obviously I love
spreading the religion of Allah spy
Nevada and that's why I'm here today now
now hold up hold up wait a minute
because you know that we have a lot of
not yet Muslims right and there are
people that don't understand Islam which
simply means to acquire peace by
submitting your will to the owner of
he's the one guy the god of Jesus
Abraham and the last and final messenger
prophet muhammad peace be upon them all
so now you said some Arabic words now
just to know if we were living during a
time of Jesus he would have spoke
Aramaic
is the sister language arabic all right
so tell us what is Sharia because some
people when you say Sharia they think
the boogeyman is coming to get you so
what is Sharia you said it what does it
mean Sharia is the law that Allah spano
Madonna legislated for mankind to govern
the lands with and it has many aspects
to it as it relates to everyone and what
I was referring to specifically is how
we govern our lives as individuals to
get closer to laughlin nevada so this
refers to the way we pray the way we
fast the way we interact and deal with
one another and you know just the way we
live our daily lives and and you said
Allah now people stink to some Arab
guard who is allah subhana wattana a la
spinetta allah and i wish you know it
was possible to do justice of a
description in me awards but allah span
wada is the creator the sustainer and
the one who solely deserves to be
worshipped linguistically speaking the
word Allah comes from alila the one who
is has the sole right to be worshipped
and that is what lies is this the same
God of Jesus Abraham Noah the same god
they worship this is the same God that
they worship this is the same God that
created them and this is the same God
that every prophet called to and
preached a boat that's the Allah he's
not a man or woman but the crater man
and woman exactly beautiful that's
simple not it just one more note don't
Arab Christians that have the Bible
Arabic isn't the word a law used for God
exactly that they use the exact same
word ok now those that might have had
some fears they can rest assured that
this is a way of life like you said that
all the messengers of God taught brought
preach teach and we're just doing the
same thing continuing the message
exactly that's it worshiping the One God
not his creation and you're learning
about it here on the Dean show and today
we're talking about spirituality many
people they have what's associated with
it mysticism and you got to turn off the
lights you got to set the mood ok and
you got to do something fancy and
something sometimes it's weird so so
what is spirituality really in Islam
what is it all about ok spirituality you
have to understand the nature
mankind the nature of mankind is that a
las panel data created us as human
beings who live in this world we are
meant to go out and seek our systems who
are meant to educate ourselves we're
meant to take care of our families and
meant to do all of these things but one
of the most key fundamental aspects of
our lives is taking care of our souls
alla Spina wat da dimensions in the
Quran that successful is the one who
purifies his soul and this is a goal for
each and every individual now the
reality of our times is that the vast
majority the people get so caught up in
this world that they don't focus on
purifying their souls or purifying the
hearts and in order for one to truly be
content in order if I want to truly
submit to Allah span wattana they have
to take care of their hearts and they
have to take care of their souls this is
just like the individual who has a
sickness an individual who is sick is
not truly going to be able to enjoy this
world someone gives you a gift let's
just see a really really nice car but if
you're terminally ill you have a
sickness you're not going to be able to
enjoy that car same thing with
purification of the so if you don't
purify your soul you don't purify your
heart the many blessings that a las
panatela gives you you're not going to
be able to be grateful for them you're
not going to be able to appreciate them
and you're not going to find any
serenity or tranquility in this life up
and until you purify your soul in your
heart so do you have to do some okay so
purifying your heart and if you're not
purifying your heart which this is what
Islam what the Creator wants us to do
and this is how we could be successful
that will this alleviate depression in
our lives definitely definitely a lot of
the times and people don't take care of
the sort of their souls that's what it
leads to his depression in this life
people end up losing hope in this life
the end up losing hope in God they end
up you know just giving up and up until
the fact that they start purifying their
hearts that's the state that they're
going to be in because a lot spine
without a throw of the Quran he gives
this parable of lightness in darkness
and the individual who is in light is
the one who is spiritually enlightened
who knows a la spina Watts Anna worships
almost panettone the one who is in
darkness is the one who doesn't purify
his soul doesn't know Allah nor does you
worship Allah subhanAllah now to purify
your heart do you have to what are some
of the practical things that you do
this love to guess work or is it defined
Oh clearly it is defined this is one of
the beautiful narrations of the
Companions that he was outside in nature
one day and there was a bird flapping
its wings going by and he said that the
prophet salallahu on you said I'm taught
us everything that we need to know about
our religion even this bird that is
flapping its wings in the sky so if heat
the process under taught us about to
that bird that's flapping its wings in
the sky then it is obvious that that
which is more important like purifying
one soul and heart would have been
taught to us as well so therefore when
it comes to spirituality it is not
something we guess or makeup but rather
like everything else we are confined to
the Quran in this window when we do this
and the Quran is this the verbatim word
of God the verbatim word of Allah spano
and the Sunnah is the Sunnah as we
explained in our last show is the
inspired word to the prophet salallahu
on a Misenum so while it wasn't direct
revelation the prophet sallallahu IM
sinem was inspired with these words
about the religion about this world and
as which we use as a form of guidance
now before I go to my next question just
to bring this point home can we make a
correlation between the two like during
Moses's time for example did he have a
revelation that was given to him and
then you had to follow his way his
Sunnah exactly each and every prophet
they had their revelation you know Moses
alehissalaam peace be upon him had the
Torah Jesus had the gospel da-daddy
salam had the Psalms and then on top of
that the people had to follow their
example and their interpretation of
those various texts so similarly as
muslims alla Spina donna sent down the
Quran to the prophet salallahu our new
salem and we follow his example of
interpreting and implementing licuado
that makes so much sense so you have the
instruction manual and the
representative exact was explaining it
so it's not my interpretation or what I
think it should be like like it's how
the messenger at that time is defining
it and today we have the last and final
messenger exactly Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon the lulav on yourself exactly
alright good we're going to take a break
if you don't mind I went right back on
the news of the prey as if everything
depends on a lot
but you must work everything depends on
you and it does that's my point you see
I'm same and I don't like that I don't
like us sitting here what are you
waiting for what are we waiting for
right now what do you wait for all these
people that come to this but what are
you waiting for what are we waiting for
right now when they're gonna come
they're gonna come along and bring these
people lost upon the water put in our
hands the ability to do it now do your
job
I am not afraid to stay alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if a las papas I i
am not afraid to stand alone i am not
afraid to stand alone if a las patas I i
am not afraid to stay alone i am not
afraid to stand alone if a las vacas I i
am not afraid to stay
please be with you welcome back to the
Dean show and we're talking about
spiritual development very important key
I'm going to tell you my experience way
back when when I started to come to a
realization like you know what this life
is short and I'm going to die soon I was
very nervous I was like you know I got
to get myself together it's not all
about just having fun and living from
friday to friday and then work party and
play so i ended up trying to really
investigate i started comparing all the
different religions and i went through
my journey and you know getting serious
wanted to know what's the purpose of
life etc etc and i started to
investigate its LOM and everything was
coming to to making sense but now I
wanted to I was feeling something my
soul was yearning for some I didn't have
all the correct understanding so I would
because of the outside influences you
see some people they'll get full of the
Holy Ghost and you're looking for this
this feeling inside like something's
going to overtake you and what I did was
I I literally shut the lights out I
didn't know anything so I shut the
lights off and I did I put some who haha
and I put some music you know some some
you know this is what I was ignorant I
didn't know and I and I was just waiting
there and I was about I was I was I was
saying some words you know praising God
and I was waiting for something to
happen something to come up please just
take me I didn't know is this what we're
talking about this is absolutely not
what my intention was good the intention
was good and each other you'll be
rewarded for your intention but when it
comes to Islam not only do we require
righteous intentions but we require
righteous actions as well and this is
refers to you know following the example
of the positive salam and of his
companions so this was something that
many people I think there is a
misconception here many people they feel
that you know what because you'll hear
again from the outside influence that
I'm full of the they call it the Holy
Spirit we have anything like this in
Islam no we don't have anything like
that in this low so okay so continue on
talking to us about the proper way that
God Almighty wants us how to develop
this purification of the heart excellent
ok so the essence of spirituality is to
become more sincere to Allah span
without to develop that closer
relationship with Allah
metana the best ways to do this or one
of the best ways to do this is
contemplate death itself time to play
the contemplate death but a scary though
it is very very scary but it brings you
back to reality it gives you a reality
check that the lives that we live our
very limited and there is a life which
is everlasting in the hereafter and you
have to make a conscious decision of
which a group of people do you want to
be of the people of heaven or the people
of hell and with that reality check you
can't help but to become more sincere
and the action that you do you can't
help but be more focused in the action
that you choose to do so that's the
number one thing and this is seen from
the hadith of the prophet salallahu our
newest setup where he said remember the
destroyer of pleasures he said remember
this destroyer of pleasures remember
death frequently and this is why you
would see some of the Companions they
would dig up their graves and while
they're alive they will go and lay down
in it and that is like the ultimate
reality check that no matter how much
power you have no matter how much money
you have how much authority you have
each and every individual one day he's
going to end up in that place and it's
actually a very very scary thought now
not only death wouldn't of itself but
leading up to death it has a profound
effect I'll tell you one story that
really really struck me who's taller I
was at an event in March last year and
in this event we were told the story of
nuh joshi he was the Abyssinian king who
was originally Christian but accepted
Islam and the prophet salallahu a new
person I've never met him but when the
jack she passed away the fafsa Lala
hannover salam made this profound
statement he said matter Lyon what
Algernon Saudi that today a righteous
man has passed away and I thought to
myself span Allah what a beautiful
ending that must have been that the
prophets of allah valley of salaam
himself is testifying to this man's
righteousness and if he had any mistakes
or any sins that he had committed he has
the best of mankind seeking his
forgiveness in janessa so I thought to
myself you know if anyone ever wanted a
good ending that would have been like
the superb ish depending that the
prophet salallahu sending himself
testifies to his righteousness then when
they prayed his funeral prayer they're
seeking his forgiveness as well and a
las final Thunder would definitely
answer that
likewise if you look at the death of the
Prophet sallallahu a new Asylum I want
to paint a picture for you over here the
prophet salallahu on even when he died
he went through a lot of agony through a
lot of pain and in that pain he's lying
on the lap of eyeshadow de la junta his
most beloved wife the most beloved think
to him in this world and during all of
that he just kept looking at the sky he
would raise his hands and then when he
passed away from this world he said
allah huma fair offical allah o allah in
the highest of companionship and those
were the last words the prophet
salallahu i never said i muttered so
through that pain through that agony
through being with the love of this
world with I shall ideale on had the
epitome of love for him he was still
longing for a la spinetta that's why you
see not win of death itself but even
stories relating to death you can't help
but purify your soul can't help but
purify your heart is that getting like
some people go to the gym to get that
pump some people go to the club to get
some high some people take some drugs
also to get that feeling right does
thinking about death it gives you
another feeling that feeling of a
reality check it gives you the feeling
of the reality check and I'll tell you
how it actually works when you think
about death it actually breaks you down
it makes you feel worthless but then you
go through the cycle that once you were
broken down you start building back up
now this build building back up it
actually makes you a better person and
that's what the reality check is all
about that you start doing those actions
that are conducive towards righteousness
you'll start praying more you'll pray on
time you'll read more quote on the
afterlife is on in mind it's always in
focus so if you're haunting now you got
some title mr. president or mr. CEO or I
missed a big shot now think about death
the destroyer of pleasures and now you
realize I'm gonna have some dirt in my
mouth where I'm going to be Six Feet
Under now you come back to reality and
you humble yourself exactly and then you
start to maybe beseech the Creator more
and say you know if I'm returning to you
I want to return in a good state
definitely definitely that's why so give
us now that's one we're almost out of
time thinking contemplating on death
this is for your betterment so you can
be more sincere in acts of worship tell
us some more please okay another thing
to focus on is where you stand in
front of all US patent with either your
relationship with him the price
predecessors they used to say never look
at the size of your sin but look at the
greatness of the one whom you're sinning
against so now when it comes to
committing sin a lot of people have this
mentality oh this is just a small sin or
this you know this is just am I
understand it's not that big of a deal
but if you look at the predecessors they
never looked at it this way every single
sin that they committed was something
heavy on their shoulders a burden that
they had that they have to alleviate
themselves from and this is why you have
the the beautiful statement from the
companion that the hypocrite he
considers his sin just like a fly that
lands on your nose he waves it away and
he thinks that the sin is gone whereas
the believer he considers his sin a
heavy weight upon his shoulders like
mountains that he carries it with him up
and until he seeks forgiveness from
Allah spano at ahana so always look at
your relationship with a la spinetta
Anna to share a nice story with you in
terms of how our relationship with Allah
Spano metallic should be all modern off
the pub he had a grandson his name was
seldom whose is this is one of the just
for our viewers to know this one of the
Companions he wasn't one of us he was
one of the Companions and he was the
second Khalifa of Islam he had a
grandson by the name of Salem and Sodom
was a profound individual he used to
live in Mecca and the hell if I went to
go see him one day so the Khalifa goes
to see him while he's making pho off and
he says Oh Salem I want to ask you a
question please answer it for me do you
have any need in this world that I can
fulfill for you do need any money salen
gave him something profound he said if
you and I were her guests in the house
of someone would you ask me to have you
renewed for a field or would you ask the
host himself the Khalifa said I would
ask the host so he said here we are in
the house of Allah soprano Tirana do you
think I'm going to ask you or where they
ask the host himself the Khalifa left to
me lady did they left the Haram and now
the Khalifa wants his revenge he waits
for Santa to come out and he thinks that
now that they're outside of the harem
he'll have him so he goes up to sell him
and he says oh sell them I ask you the
same question again is there any need of
yours that needs to be fulfilled any
money that you may need he said let me
ask you a question or Khalifa do you
actually own this wealth or are you just
put in charge of it the Khalifa says I'm
just put in charge of it so he says what
I ask the owner
of the wealth or just the one who's put
in charge and he said obviously the one
who owns the suave and the Holly far
left again and he told his people his
entourage did they not tell you this was
a special person so our ultimate goal is
to turn everything back to Alice panna
mudiyala in terms all of the blessings
that came from Allah soprano with Dada
this is that we commit we're seeking a
less forgiveness everything that we do
we're trying to keep a list panel down
in mind so before we go to break so
Allah he's the most merciful the most
forgiving we just got to have our
actions in line with all the good things
he's told us to do exactly stay away
from all the bad things just try your
best that's all that's required and this
is only going to better our lives
definitely let's take a break and we'll
be right back on the DS show
they're always be someone there will be
there to say something negative but at
the same time there'll be someone there
to say some positive awesome just hold
on to the Rope of Allah everything in
this universe rely I need a last minute
the Quran says don't kill women don't
kill children don't feel the old people
don't attack the civilians this is what
the Prophet Muhammad told us it will
fail you mocking oh Allah so that the
prophet saw silent never ever start a
war against anything so if you find
yourself your Iman is going down check
yourself there is nano woody to be
worship except Allah alone you got some
serious of music in the car bobbing your
head the fifty cents oh no it's common
sense don't do things that can hurt
people Lady Gaga googoo and all that
other nonsense bullying is head on back
biting slandering and such substances
that smoking stay to 18 inch pie except
we'll see what happens to Eddie on the
TV show and we holdin it down on a game
show Fairly make sure y'all tune back on
the Dean show and we are talking about
spiritual development and the time is so
short but we just want to give people a
taste a better understanding and then
they can go on and continue getting
motivated to seek knowledge and
implement all the good knowledge that we
have authentic knowledge that's from the
creator of the heavens and earth tell us
now it's the same thing like a person is
a law-abiding citizen you should be a
law abiding citizen right definitely
should obey the law of the land but now
you know a person doesn't want to get
locked up for disorderly conduct a
person doesn't want to get locked up for
you know let's say parking tickets or
whatever it is these are crimes you
don't want to commit crimes exactly is
it the same thing now with the law of
God we don't want to break the law of
the land nor should we want to break the
law of God is more important definitely
and you know there's actually a nice
parallel over here that when you commit
a crime in the society that you say they
got a driving offense you end up paying
a ticket and that's
it's over but whereas when you commit a
sin against god it actually places a
black dot on your heart and that's the
heart had stains the heart and the more
sins that you commit to the heart of
your heart becomes and the harder it
becomes for you to connect to God and it
becomes such a bad state that one is no
longer able to distinguish between right
and wrong one longs for closeness to God
but it's unable to attain it and that is
like one of the worst forms of
punishment in this world so just like
people would pay you know parking
tickets and would pay these things off
the way to get those black dots off of
ours is to seek forgiveness from such
forgiveness you look at the best example
in the Prophet sallallahu ala salaam
himself he said that I seek forgiveness
from Allah 70 200 times a day if not
more than that and this is an individual
whom all of his sins are already
forgiven it's guaranteed but just to due
to the fact that Allah loves this act of
seeking forgiveness he used to do it
throughout the day so the best way to do
this is just frequent the statement of
stuff fear Allah anyway you're going
keep it on your tongue in your such de
seek forgiveness from Allah spinal
tirana and you will find him to be
compassionate and worship so he's
showing us through example that God
loves this earnest seeking of
forgiveness and the Prophet peace be
upon him did it not because he was like
some big sinner like some people you
know the misconception all he sought
forgiveness so you know right this is
not the case not at all so this is again
to show us and to because God Almighty
Allah loves this exactly exactly so
never give up or despair the mercy of
God never ever this is again from the
beauty of its time that an individual
comes into Islam his sins are wiped out
completely like I'm talking about clean
white slate no sense whatsoever same
thing for the Muslim himself when he
seeks his forgiveness when he does good
deeds God wipes out those sins for him
closing comments and suggestions we
covered reality remembering death
sincerity and seeking forgiveness one
last possessions yes one last piece of
advice a la spina without a cent down
this revelation known as the Quran it is
a very blessed revelation the clearest
signs of this is an individual who
recites it and reflects over it it will
move his heart and this is what I want
to invite you to bit in a katana we
started with peace we end with peace
peace beyond
you thank you for being on thank you
very much does that we are thank you and
thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Dean show again you got
to hear some great advice remember the
destroyer of pleasures death it could
come at any time so humble yourself in
front of the most high the most great
the creator of this universe and
everything in it he created us and he
created everything and he's given us
everything and now we have to beseech
him for the guidance it's that simple
it's that easy start to earnestly ask
for forgiveness ask for guidance and
then be courageous enough to take those
steps forward to live on the truth to be
on the truth and to die on the truth and
visit us here every week on the Dean
show until next time peace be unto you
he created the universe to him belong
the heavens and lil Lil 11 he is the
first he's the polymers he stamped his
messengers to all his creatures
on the grave danger Oh worshipping Allah
then Allah there is none greater and
more Creator oh there is none greater
than love